we've heard a bit about customers in the
last few segments not surprisingly
customers will play a huge role in the
success or failure of your business are
they giving you money or aren't they
there are a few metrics you should keep
in mind in terms of customers loyalty
retention and acquisition costs customer
loyalty measures the performance of your
customers how often they purchase how
often they visit a site basically have
they made your product a habit customer
retention then measures the number of
users retained in a given time period
and this is particularly important for
subscription-based models which we'll
learn more about later you can calculate
customer retention by taking the total
number of customers at the end of the
given period and subtracting the total
number of new customers that you got
during that period and you divide that
all by the customers that you had at the
start of the period multiply that by 100
and you'll get a percentage customer
acquisition cost as the name implies is
how much you spend to acquire new users
you can calculate customer acquisition
cost by taking the total acquisition
expenses and dividing by the total
number of new users in a given period
now what constitutes good for each of
these metrics is really up to you
obviously a 100 percent customer
retention percentage would be ideal but
it's also not very likely you'll be
referring to these metrics a lot later
on once you've implemented a
monetization method and are looking to
iterate on it so take a moment to think
about what success might look like for
your product you'll be referring to
these metrics a lot later on once you've
implemented a monetization number and
are looking to iterate on it so take a
moment to think about what success might
look like for your product what metrics
might you use to measure customer
loyalty
what percentage of customers do you
reasonably hope to retain use this box
to record your response